do you think alpha fold
two or something similar to it from deep
mind or somebody
else will be will result
in a nobel prize or multiple nobel
prizes
so like the you know obviously maybe not
so obviously
you can't give a nobel prize to the
computer program
uh you at least for now give it to the
designers of that program
but is do you see one or multiple nobel
prizes
where alpha fold two
is like a large percentage of what that
prize
is given for would it lead to
discoveries
at the level of nobel prizes
i mean i think
we are definitely destined to see the
nobel prize
becoming sort of to be evolving
with the evolution of science and the
evolution in science as such
that it now becomes like really
multifaceted right so where you have you
don't really have like
a unique discipline you have sort of the
the
a lot of cross disciplinary talks in
order to achieve
uh sort of you know really big
advancements
uh you know so i
think you know the computational methods
will be acknowledged in one way or
another and
in as a matter of fact uh you know
they were first acknowledged back in
2013
right where you know the first
three uh people were uh you know
awarded the the nobel prize for the pro
for studying the protein folding right
the principle
and you know i think all three of them
are computational by physicists
right so um you know that
i think is is inavoidable
you know it will come with the time
um the fact that
you know alpha fold and you know similar
approaches because
again it's a matter of time that people
will embrace
the this uh you know principle and
we'll see more and more such uh you know
such tools
coming into play but uh you know these
methods will be critical
in uh in a scientific discovery
no no doubts about it
you